it's the biggest diplomatic gathering in
the world with delegations from all the
countries that the members of the United
Nations in two and a half years heading
the UN secretary-general Antonio
Guterres has made great efforts to
resolve the world's most deadly
conflicts but with little progress in an
interview for Al Jazeera's planet SOS he
told me he wants the focus of this
year's high-level week on an issue he
says is even more important climate the
threat of each of these conflicts is to
a certain extent localized and climate
change became a global threat for
humankind and the global set for the
planet and things are evolving in such a
way that climate change became an
accelerated of conflict with tension
growing between the u.s. Saudi Arabia
and Iran the situation in the Gulf will
be high on the agenda and one of the
UN's most experienced diplomats told me
with so many key players in the same
place at the same time there could be
important developments things can move
very fast and it would be foolish to
rule something out on grounds of
ideology when as you say you've got all
these world leaders and foreign
ministers together it does mean that
reactions can be very Swift
and initiatives can be taken privately
without having to have the full
publicity of a leader fly in or go
somewhere every year the General
Assembly week gets busier and busier
today the count is 90 once heads of
state six vice presidents 45 heads of
government five deputy Prime Minister's
the number of meetings requested has now
climbed to 630 this part of the UN the
visitors Lobby is normally open to the
public but during the high-level week
it's one of the most secure places on
earth all around the UN temporary rooms
have been set up these are what are
known as bilateral booths you can see
the leather chairs the table there's
room here for two or more delegations to
meet at short notice if necessary in
some privacy
organizing this event is a mammoth
operation insiders have told me just
getting the motorcades of presidents
prime ministers and foreign ministers
here so they can speak back to back on
the podium is an operation akin to air
traffic control James BAE's al-jazeera
of the United Nations